Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you’re watching
the Today I Found Out YouTube channel, in
the video today, we’re looking at why the
cheddar cheese you find on shelves at supermarkets
is often some shade of orange when milk is
white.
Milk is made up of about 87% water and 13%
solids, such as fat and various proteins.
Chief among these proteins is something called
casein, four types of which make up about
80% of the proteins in milk.
The casein protein molecules are typically
suspended somewhat uniformly throughout the
milk and are spherical, about a micrometer
across.
The reason they are somewhat uniformly suspended
in the liquid is because kappa-casein molecules
have a negative electrical charge, so they
repel each other.
White objects in nature appear such when there
is some level of light diffusion going on
and no part of the visible spectrum gets reflected
off the object any more than any other part
of that area of the light spectrum.
As you might guess from that, these casein
proteins and some of the fats in the milk
scatter and deflect light somewhat uniformly
throughout the visual spectrum.
This results in milk being fairly opaque and
appearing white to our eyes.
This brings us back to the question at hand-
if milk is white, why is cheddar cheese such
a striking orange-ish / yellow color?
Before more modern industrialized milk farming,
cows grazed in pastures abundant with beta-carotene-rich
grasses.
As they digest the naturally orange-ish pigment
in the grass, it is stored in their fat cells.
When a cow gives milk, the beta-carotene-colored
milk fat is secreted in globules, primarily
made of triglyceride surrounded by a lipid
membrane, which itself is surrounded by protein
clusters.
While the cow's milk will usually still appear
mostly white in the human visual spectrum,
depending on the type of cow, the time of
year, and the fields it's grazing in, this
beta-carotene laden fat can turn the milk
an off-white, or in the extreme, a slightly
golden color.
With traditional cheddar cheese making, the
beta-carotene infused fat is left in the milk,
and after the rennet, bacteria and heat work
their magic on the liquid, the protein clusters
release their grip on the globules and their
membranes dissolve, such that they are no
longer opaque, making the beta-carotene a
little more visible.
Once the whey is drained and pressed out,
the fat is also more concentrated in the final
product than it was in the original milk.
Thus, since the color comes from the beta-carotene
in the fat, for those cheeses made this way
(as opposed to things like higher acid cheeses
or those made with goat or buffalo milk),
those with the higher fat content will tend
to take on a yellow-ish hue.
Accordingly, cheddar, with approximately 32%
fat content (compared to, say, whole milk
mozzarella at about 17%) classically was a
slight golden color (akin to butter that hasn't
been dyed), rather than the distinct orange/yellow
color we typically associate with cheddar
today.
So why the change to deeper colors?
According to Professor Paul Kindstedt of the
University of Vermont, this started around
the 16th/17th century in England.
At this time, certain cheese makers began
skimming some of the cream off the milk to
sell separately before making the cheddar,
lowering the fat content, but still producing
relatively tasty cheese.
This practice resulted in much paler, even
white, cheddars, which consumers found (and
still find) less desirable.
To mask the true fat content, the farmers
began adding color back in.
Common colorants included marigold petals,
carrot juice and even saffron, but most cheese
makers ultimately settled on annatto, a relatively
cheap and available seed containing pigments
that will turn things a lovely yellow-orange,
depending on concentration.
When cheese-making became industrialized in
the 19th century, many companies chose to
continue the practice of dying certain cheeses
like cheddar and, for marketing reasons, the
exact hue of the cheese continued to move
away from the classic light gold to more of
the orange-ish / yellow we have today.
Beyond any form of agri-fraud certain 16th/17th
century cheese makers sometimes employed,
this was something of a necessity on an industrial
scale given that the manufacturers used milk
from numerous different farms to make their
products.
Given the end color of the cheese could vary
greatly based on things like the time of year,
exact diet of the cows, and cattle used (Guernsey
and Jersey cattle, for instance, tend to produce
richer colored milk), it was very difficult
to get a consistent color in a given brand's
product without dying the cheddar.
And as consumers, much like today, strongly
preferred near-pumpkin colored cheddars, the
practice of dying the cheddar was a handy
and cheap marketing trick.
Speaking of diet, over the last couple centuries,
many milk farmers have shifted away from primarily
pasture-feeding their cattle to providing
a dry feed diet.
One of the key benefits to this is that the
farmer can ensure a much more consistent tasting
end product, though there does appear to be
some sacrifice in nutritional value in doing
this.
More pertinent to this video, another negative
side effect, at least as far as many consumers
are concerned, is the dry feed diet lacks
the beta-carotene of the pasture grasses,
making the cheddar white, regardless of fat
content, again requiring the annatto seeds
to get the color consumers want.
Many butter manufacturers dye their butters
yellow for similar reasons, regardless of
the quality of the butter itself or the diets
of the cattle producing the milk- a noticeable
golden color is simply what people expect
the color of butter to be and if it's not,
they'll usually buy the brand that offers
that color.